attrape c'était une visite éclair mais
non moins chargées d'histoire avec une
participante inédite
josette et fille de cheminot elle a
grandi dans cette cité d'un bout à
l'autre des dents si c'était que des
enfants qui jouent et voilà c'est tout
les souvenirs qui reviennent les bon et
le mauvais il n'ya pas toujours que des
bons temps n'avait rien
87 ans d'histoire présentée par mémoire
de trappes les dents de scie secret avec
l'arrivée des chemins de fer et au
déploiement du triage c'est un habitat
qui étaient conçus spécialement pour eux
et qui est issu un peu de pas mal de
courants architecturaux et puis courant
hygiéniste aussi qu'ils vont se déployer
donc entre les deux guerres c'est un
artiste qui a beaucoup travaillé pour
saint quentin en yvelines
son style s'est inscrit le figuratif
comme vous pouvez le voir et ses
conseils et composée en fait de 12
éléments peu près les oeuvres de denis
mondino décrypter expliqué pour sa
balade patrimoniale le musée de la ville
s'est placée sous le signe de l'europe
il faut imaginer que saint quentin en
yvelines du temps de la ville nouvelle
du temps de l'édification en fait de
cette ville était un véritable champ une
page blanche pour tous ses artistes et
ses architectes qui venait collaborer à
l'édification de cette ville nouvelle
l'art public était associé dès le départ
de la création de la ville nouvelle sur
saint quentin en yvelines
martha panne de nîmes en dîner ou encore
massimiliano fuksas ont été mis à
l'honneur
une dizaine de curieux ainsi pu
découvrir des problématiques de la
conservation et la préservation d'une
oeuvre très surpris parce que je passe
régulièrement mais effectivement d
j'ignorais tout ce qui se passe derrière
et tout ce qui est autour de la
restauration et d'entretien des oeuvres
ça m'a bien fait découvrir marmont mon
territoire
parce que vraiment il ya des endroits je
connaissais pas du tout pour ces
journées européennes du patrimoine une
trentaine de l'ue ont ouvert leurs
portes le temps d'un week end